being a traditional short seller again
you were never out there trying to make
absolute returns except in down years
but again for guys like us you know
we're more active as short sellers we're
like investigative journalists digging
into companies to expose dark secrets
and rather than selling subscriptions
and ads we take risks and trade
alongside these investigative reports so
it's it's different from what most
traditional short sellers did
[Music]
all right guys bang bang I've got Carson
here with me Carson I thought a great
place for us to start this conversation
is this idea of a re-appearance of Short
Selling but there's kind of two
different stories from my external view
we have on one side uh folks like
yourself or Hindenburg research who have
these great track records of shorting
stocks coming out and kind of exposing a
lot of uh whether they're actual frauds
or kind of mismanagement and just bad
behavior in the market kind of a check
on you know the people who are just
Ultra Bulls Ultra long all the time on
the other side we see Short Selling
coming up a lot when it comes to these
meme stocks and these short squeezes
that are occurring it appears that
usually the people who are shorting
there are kind of more traditional hedge
funds that don't necessarily specialize
just in shorting can you give us a
little bit of your understanding or kind
of like your view as to on one side it
seems like short selling is working and
people are making money and they're
calling out the bad companies on the
other side it seems like people are
getting blown up left and right and you
know people on Reddit are having the a
field day and it's like which one is it
right well it can be both
um and I think what a lot of people
don't understand about what we do as
activist short sellers so short selling
itself is a niche and activist Short
Selling is a niche within a niche and
the the issue is
um some vast majority of the shortable
universe consists of companies that are
just basically melting ice cubes so if
you're going to short it you have you
think it's melting faster than whoever's
on the other side of this thinks it's
melting
um and that's that's fine but for
activist short sellers that's not what
we do we're not going out in the least
good activist short seller isn't going
out and screaming like I think the
competition is going to erode margins
faster than the street does my model
beats that like no the Crux of what we
do is we're looking for situations in
which
generally management has has manipulated
the information that it's giving to
investors and that's usually so that
management can pump the stock and dump
it sometimes it's because they're you
know they're able to get the companies
to engage in transactions with companies
they have interests in but in any event
it's it's when management is
misleading egregiously misleading or
outright lying or concealing you know
lies of omission
um concealing material information so
that's where activist short sellers come
into play and we're not usually looking
forward to say we think this is what's
going to happen we're Looking Backward
the company told you this this was
misleading because blah blah blah and
they didn't tell you that and so you
know up to you investor you know you
extrapolate the future based on a past
that you've just been shown was a lot
less positive than you thought it was so
that's that's what activist short
sellers do and
you know it really in the post GFC
environment
um you know it's it just seems like
every public company CEO it feels like
it's his god-given right to monetize at
least like 50 million dollars worth of
stock and the environment is has been so
corroded because like you know pretty
much in so many of these companies are
really pushing you know they're they're
close to the line in a lot of respects
and I guess what's different is the long
side at least you know until maybe 22
and are arguably still the case though
alongside began cheering this on because
it became clear in the post-gfc world
that on the long side you were no longer
being remunerated for caring about risk
right so the guys who cared about risk
got derided as value investors and sort
of laughed into a corner and you know
the dudes who are like yeah give me some
narrative give me some blue pill I'm
gonna Crush that up and you know
blow some rails those were the people
who were you know awarded financially so
um that's why there is this there's
still this target Rich environment for
activist short sellers is because the
behaviors just become so pervasive and
so egregious on the part of company
management now
when you look at the bigger picture and
these and how you've got more and more
fun saying okay we're not going to do
single name shorts anymore so that's
that there's somewhat different Dynamics
there so
most long short funds historically the
dirty secret is they didn't really care
about shorting it's just a way to get a
higher fee structure right like they're
trying to make their money on the long
side and you know charge a 2 and 20
instead of just being paid you know like
like 100 bips on you know on assets
under management so they were sort of
reluctantly shorting now
those you know those are the pretend
shorters as well as the real ones
they're usually looking for the melting
Ice Cube type of shorts and um you know
that's fine but really that was never a
strategy that was designed to make money
it was not an absolute return strategy
it's like we're looking to generate
Alpha so you know we're going to be you
know we're like you know we're like 150
gross and we're you know we're net long
50 and you know we're just trying to
create Alpha uh with our shorts and
every now and then you have a year in
which the market goes down and that's
when those shorts are are actually going
to provide some absolute return but by
and large you're doing it to smooth
volatility
um so that generally worked except the
problem is allocators got really tired
of losing money
um you know on the short side because
you know I mean at least until you know
late 21 22 the market was just going up
that's it so so you had that Dynamic and
then something else that also I think a
lot of
um a lot of short sellers you know have
been in the game a long time because
look the reality is you haven't had a
lot of people since the financial crisis
come out of the woodwork to say you know
I want to be a traditional short seller
so these are mostly people who were you
know whose careers started well before
the GFC
what they don't understand is when they
look at their book and they say well I'm
short you know 50 different names or 30
different names
um so there's diversification there
they're short the same factors in many
cases so you know and this this is
something this is a more sophisticated
way of looking at Market movements and
understanding them is looking at what
factors are actually responsible for the
movement so it's no longer just saying
you know beta drives markets it's
factors style factors like momentum or
you could have you know Tech
Etc so when you're short when you have
when you're concentrated in these
factors in your short book
you know and and something moves against
you
um I mean like especially the guys who
were shorting kind of the scammy little
companies or the ones that are out ahead
of themselves they're short the momentum
factor and so when momentum starts you
know popping I mean they took real
losses so that's part of the reason that
even prior to the meme stock phenomenon
a lot of funds that were running short
books decided that they were going to do
short indices instead of shorting single
names or short ETFs
um with the meme stock thing
yeah I mean it's it's just one more
thing that you know it's a it's another
bitter pill I guess for short sellers
because it's like hey you've got all of
these retail investors who individually
are pretty small but they band together
in order to pursue completely
non-economic Behavior you know like what
are you gonna do about that like if you
know if if they're gonna say yeah I'm
proudly going long you know AMC you know
or or Tupperware I mean yeah what do you
do if they want to be non-economic so
it's um you know it it's being a
traditional short seller again you were
never out there trying to make absolute
returns except in down years
um but it's it's only been worse and
harder
but again for guys like us you know
we're more activist short sellers we're
like investigative journalists digging
into companies to expose dark secrets
and rather than selling subscriptions
and ads
you know we we take risk and trade
alongside these investigative reports so
it's it's different from what most
traditional short sellers did
tell me a little bit about like the
anatomy of one of these deals right so
how do you guys come up with the ideas
is it somebody giving you a tip are you
guys doing a kind of on the ground
research do you have kind of a bucket of
names and you're like okay let's see if
we can go find you know kind of a thread
to start polling like maybe like where
do the ideas come from and then in each
one is probably a little different but
like what is the process at which you
then say okay we've got a kernel of
information that we believe this could
be a potential fraud or misleading or
whatever how do you get and build the
conviction to eventually go put a short
on where if you're wrong and you put a
report out you're drawing attention to
the name it could go against you right
and people say no actually we disagree
and you lose money so like how do you
build that conviction where do these
ideas come from
sure well I'll take I'll take the second
idea first because it'll help inform
them where where the ideas come from so
the when you when you look at our
process I'd say they're basically two
stages to it so
if if you were a if you were say a tiger
cub which they generally do they will
short the fraudy type companies the
stock promotions that's been a tiger
specialty so
by the time they get conviction
internally and they have the meeting and
say yeah this you know this sounds like
this this is a problem at a company
let's put some risk on let's short it so
we probably take more or less the same
amount of time to get to that level
where we say this isn't this is a
problem at a company not call it two or
three weeks
but the issue for us is we're going to
go public and you know I I I've referred
to this as market-based prosecution like
we're we're trying to build a case
against the company and often the
individual managers of the company in
the public and we're not trying to talk
to other short Sellers and say you know
you should short this like actually we
don't want that we don't want other guys
shorting it and crowding it because it
does make it more squeezy we're talking
to the Longs so what is going to be you
know so we need to present an
overwhelming case that's going to make
Longs say wow I didn't know this I've
been misled you know what I gotta I
gotta reevaluate this position here and
um it's hard because a lot of people on
the long side they get really defensive
you know and they take it almost as a
personal affront like you're challenging
their their intelligence and like you
can be a really really sharp investor
and you can still get scanned and you
can and I've been defrauded hard even in
the past 13 years that I've been doing
this like I was the victim of a major
Master fraud carried out right under my
nose
um so it's not that you know so
unfortunately when Longs take these
things as insults to their intelligence
they shouldn't I mean it's you know it
but in any event that's the type of
resistance that we're going to meet and
everybody wants us to be wrong everybody
on the long side wants us to be wrong
and the companies are going to come back
with everything they have they're
spending other people's money to try to
throw oftentimes throw like a tidal wave
of public relations at us
um to try to you know to basically you
know try to push the stock back up and
get out of trouble so that's what that
will take months for us
I mean we've taken you know in some
cases over a year to build the case and
it it depends on exactly what the thesis
is but a lot of times it involves field
work so we've we've done some stuff
recently
um you know late last year and we've
talked a little bit about it this year
as well we're short a European company
um
your German and UK real estate
um and we were short the bonds so this
isn't something that U.S investors know
but you know they've been taking
valuation gains on their assets you know
because basically they say oh you know
it used to be worth 30 million euro uh
yeah now it's worth 40 million euro and
they're borrowing against this inflated
base
so we send investigators out like well
this building is completely shut down
it's covered with graffiti it's got
broken windows looks like a real piece
of like how are you going to say
that it's suddenly worth like 10 million
more Euro and worth 40 million euro
which you know we know it's x square
meters roughly on a per square meter
basis is way too high so that's the type
of thing we'll do we also pull filings
from around the world and this is one of
the things that's interesting you know
the us we consider to be a very
transparent jurisdiction but it's not
when it comes to corporate filings but I
mean Europe Asia you know like pretty
much all around the world we can get in
interesting information including
subsidiary financials and you know we'll
look at those things and sometimes the
subsidiary financials don't add up to
what's been reported in the SEC
Consolidated financials so that's
something else we do
um we'll talk to Industry experts and we
want to make sure that we understand the
way the business should look we speak to
a lot of former employees and when we
have these conversations we don't do so
as Muddy Waters so we usually do those
through these you know expert or
Consulting networks so we're paying you
know like twelve hundred dollars an hour
for a call or something like that and
you know it's important to us that we
position ourselves as potential long
investors in the stock because we don't
want somebody to go in and think like oh
you know if they'll be happy if I give
them the negative stuff you know we're
trying to get them to think we we want
the positive and if negative things
start to come out then we then we drill
into it but those are really the tools
of the trade plus a significant amount
of accounting analysis on the the actual
Consolidated financials and the
disclosures now
where do the ideas come from
um
as you noted there are four there are
far fewer funds that are shorting single
names so we did used to get pitched
ideas all the time the way that funds
Once Upon a Time if they were short
something that was kind of scammy they
would go to the traditional media to
pitch a story like Enron
um well the media is generally not in
the business traditional media is
generally not in the business of
reporting
um you know bad things of doing
investigative reporting into companies
because the economics of of that are
just not there just takes way too much
in the way of resources a lot of people
don't want to read long-form journalism
and they just don't need the threats and
the action or actual you know litigation
so
they would come to us now again that has
dried up somewhat because you know a lot
of fun stopped doing single name
shorting but you know for us I mean we
we're looking a lot of times and it
sounds almost flippant to say this but
we're looking for the stuff that seems
too good to be true so if there's a lot
of money flowing into a particular into
a particular industry you know the the
scammers are going to come out of the
woodwork and so it's not necessarily the
first company in the space that goes
public not necessarily the second but by
the time you're on the third or fourth
company going public in a given space to
try to capitalize on the money grab
there's probably something to do there
companies that have significant assets
or operations in emerging or Frontier
markets
um always you know worth looking at
um companies with complex accounting so
it's you know then a lot of times it's
just following people around like
certain you know key shareholders or
stock promoters or investment Banks or
even lawyers you you know following them
around and seeing what they're involved
in and you know because these guys once
you're in scam stock world you generally
don't get hired into legitimate company
world so you know every few years
they'll pop up in a new place and you
know we we look for those guys what is
the ESG grift I know it's something that
you've talked a lot about and it's one
of these industries where a lot of money
has flowed we now are starting to see
analysis of like esg's all over
someone's website the portfolio may not
reflect the ESG you know kind of uh
talking that they're doing we're now
even seeing some people say well hold on
a second some of the actions we're
taking that are ESG friendly may
actually be hurting certain countries or
companies like what what is kind of your
take on that whole world right now
well I mean there's a lot to unpack
there and um but I mean at a high level
one of the you know the issue is
there are a lot of subsidies at stake
and so the companies that have become
really big are the ones that are best at
hoovering up the subsidies and they're
not doing it by coloring within the
lines so for example if you look at
Sunrun and this is you know I think
largely true of the other major
residential solar companies
um there are these investment tax
credits that you get if you put a solar
system on your roof and the vast
majority of Sunrun customers don't
actually buy the systems outright from
Sunrun if they did they would pay
roughly three dollars a watt for the
system but what they do instead is they
enter into Power purchase agreements
with sun run so Sunrun installs at its
own cost it installs the system on the
roof and basically you agree that you're
going to buy Power from it for 20 to 25
years and so Sunrun then takes these
power purchase agreements and sometimes
their leases but it's a similar concept
they then take these power purchase
agreements and they stick them in an
entity
um and they you know and basically each
one of these power purchase agreements
entitles somebody to have an investment
tax credit so Sunrun and the other solar
companies lose money hand over fist I
mean even their ebitda is massively
negative which really takes a special
type of business to do that consistently
but these are just cash incineration
machines but so sunrun's unable to use
these investment tax credits itself but
it effectively sold them by sticking
these ppas into an entity and kind of
selling off an interest that receives
the um the tax credit now the issue here
the grift is that if you go back to what
my statement that if you bought this
from Sunrun and said yeah hey I'm going
to pay cash put it on my roof you'd pay
about three dollars a watt by the time
Sunrun finishes all of these
machinations and valuation games of for
the ppas because that's what it then
gets the investment tax credit on is the
agreement not the system
they go and they claim credits that are
based on about five dollars a lot it's
like well wait how wait like if the
arm's length value is three dollars a
watt you know how is it that just
because you put a bunch of paper on it
you flip it into a different entity it's
five dollars a lot and we've gone into
this in detail but one of the but I
think the clearest most abusive tactic
that they use to juice the valuation is
when they when they say well what's this
power purchase agreement worth they
actually include the value of the
anticipated tax credit in that so like
oh well you know we're getting a tax
credit of this so that automatically
like boosts the valuation of this by you
know 20 25 and then of course now
there's a little bit more of a tax
credit so we boost it again and so it's
this iterative you know process but
you know it's just ludicrous now that's
the problem when you have is when you
have a setup and I I understand why you
know the government has certain pot you
know they've got policies that they
think are good for society let's
subsidize the private Market you know to
do this but
the problem is you're always going to
have people who are abusive and push you
know and really push the line there or
maybe or even Are Over The Line
those are the ones who are going to be
the winners the ones who are just able
to vacuum up the money the best so
that's one way in which ESG is a grift
just tremendous abuse and that's not
just in the residential solar space it's
in a lot of this green stuff wherever
there are subsidies the winners
generally are the are abusing the system
um you know then of course we have the
whole green washing thing you know
calling something sustainable and green
when it's not and then as as you alluded
to there there are a lot of questions
about like well gee you know how I mean
is is the solar panel really is green I
mean a lot of times when they talk about
you know the carbon savings they're
excluding where it's made China what
type of power is used to produce it
coal-fired power how does it get over
here diesel-powered boat and then what
happens when the sun doesn't shine well
you generally have to have a backup
generate generator online so when you
look at the utility scale uh solar
projects and wind projects they have to
have a power plant that's idling because
you can't just say okay well we're going
to flip the switch and spin it up so
it's idling and emitting carbon all the
time so when you get these accounting
when you get the accounting for the
carbon emissions a lot of times it
excludes that stuff and I'll just like
to give an example one of them I think
the most egregious examples of this type
of accounting that I've come
across
um within the EU
um companies like are countries like
Germany had shut down a number of their
coal well they they were going to shut
down their coal-fired power plants but
the way the eu's carbon accounting
system works is if you take if you stop
burning coal but you replace it with
biomass or wood that is sourced from
outside of the country then you can use
that in your coal-fired power plant I
guess there's not a lot of capex needed
to change it over and it won't count
against the country's carbon emissions
but the reality is if you're burning
wood to get a unit of energy you are
releasing far more CO2 into the
atmosphere than you would with coal
alone so they're basically saying oh
look we're reducing you know our carbon
emissions you know we're on target to
meet the eu's you know the eu's goal but
they're just burning a bunch of
trees to do that so that's part of how
the system is gamed and um and part of
why it's really
I mean just top to bottom and you know
right to left I think like like ESG is
largely aggressed and you know bottom
line is the one energy source that we
always should have focused on
was nuclear but the greens hated that
and so yeah I mean you want something
that's cheap renewable and you know and
basically Limitless yeah nuclear the
funniest part to me is when you see the
ESG company rankings come out and the
oil companies are above like Tesla right
and again like without even getting into
all the details you're like all right
something's going on here we probably
should look at
um another area where I think a lot of
people have questions and I know you've
got a lot of expertise because a good
part of your early career was actually
on companies based in China and you had
immense success in terms of finding
these businesses kind of calling them
out shorting them and not only profiting
but also I think kind of cleaning up a
lot of that market what is uh kind of
your view of U.S China relations and
even Chinese companies both based in
China and then trying to cross listen to
the US it seems like there's like a
geopolitical conversation and you know
are we in competition are we working
together maybe both you know kind of
what's going on there and then these
companies when you start looking at some
of the the legal structurings of the
Cross listings the companies that are in
China it seems like they're still frauds
that continue to pop up there like just
kind of talk a little bit about us and
China and kind of how you're viewing
those two markets right now wow yeah I
know that's that's there's really a lot
to unpack there too
um
oh boy well maybe the place to start is
you you
characterized our earlier work as having
helped clean up the space and
that was true for a moment in time but
um what happened so I
I started doing this by accident really
I was out of the markets I was living in
China I had a business there and my
father who was a microcap investor
professional investor he got really
interested in these Chinese stocks that
had listed in the U.S via reverse merger
you know they're all growing so quickly
so profitable and
um and what a you know what a gift to
American investors that they chose the
U.S list so I had no notion that there
was widespread fraud here but he asked
me to look at one company initially it
was a company called Orient paper and
you know he told me some things about it
that just seemed like red flags but I
you know I didn't really want to look at
this company because I had my own you
know just every day was like a grind you
know with my business there and it's
kicking my ass so I but ultimately this
was my father so I took a look at it and
just before going up there to take a
look at the factory that's when I
finally read the filings and it was
filled with obvious lies I mean these
filings I mean just like prices the
valuations of land of equipment I mean
just just that you know because
I've been in China and doing business
there long enough I guess I was seeing
the Matrix and I knew that these things
were lies so wrote a report exposing
that
having no idea that this was systemic
and you know immediately was contacted
by a lot of people who said you know
like these are hedge funds who'd been
shorting these things look at this one
look at that one and just opening the
10ks and like oh my God obvious fraud so
very soon realized that it was systemic
now
why was this systemic um
to some extent the the entire well the
entire Finance industry they're just
massive conflicts of interest and people
can point fingers in other directions
but that's really acute when it comes to
China But ultimately you know of all the
from the first wave of fraud so we we
then sprinted so this was June of 2010
we published this first report and
you know I'd say that this wave ended in
late 2013. most the companies value
Chinese companies valuations in the US
at least the reverse merger ones were in
the toilet by then and
um you know people the Zeitgeist was
China is uninvestable and nobody wanted
to look at Chinese companies and so what
did what had happened was you know
during that that whole wave of Fraud and
that's chronicled in uh the movie The
China hustle that you you talked about
um
only one company chairman
ever has done material jail time in the
U.S and that's because he was actually
time a citizen of Taiwan not of Maine
not of uh the PRC
um otherwise China drew a motor around
these guys and then China Chinese policy
Banks like China Development Bank
um began financing take privates of some
of these obvious complete frauds and so
investors in the U.S were actually
investors in quotes uh if you're along
these things
some of them got paid huge Premia as
these you know as these things were
taken out and so what China knew about
us that you know we evidently don't know
about ourselves is that it's really easy
to wipe out our memory so again as
China's cleaning up some of these total
frauds and most of them had just
basically gone to well below a dollar
and traded on the pink sheets if traded
at all
um by taking out a few of them
2014 comes around Alibaba is going to go
public everybody wanted Alibaba man that
was hot it was sexy this and that so all
of a sudden We're Off to the Races and
so then then you got this next wave of
Chinese IPOs and these were generally
online companies and I mean they were
they were real businesses in most cases
you know like the rtos the reverse
merger Chinese companies and from the
first wave I mean they weren't real
businesses they most of them were just
basically empty boxes with like a facade
of a of a factory but
um but these were more real and they're
online so it's harder to prove now we
would look at the filings for a number
of these things and we would see that
the tax treatments were up and
that's pretty common with these frauds
because when you're making things up you
know one lie basically leads to you know
you need like a hundred lies to cover up
one lie so that's you'd often see the
strains in the tax treatment but going
public and saying to investors who you
know were just so desperate for more
growth narrative especially you know
since the US was recovering slowly from
the GFC
um saying like hey we think it's a fraud
because this tax and these taxes don't
make sense nah people want the photos
they want the overwhelming proof and I
mean in the end of the day they didn't
want us to be right and by that point in
time we were also up against this kind
of institutional barrier which is all of
these guys who basically pegged their
careers to being long China stuff well I
mean if you're now saying this you know
these larger more established you know
companies are also frauds what are they
going to do with their careers you know
like this is you know like they'll die
on this hill and so there was so much
institutional resistance
um in those instances and then China
also overtly turned hostile to people
like us and that actually happened in
the summer of 2012 when they sent out a
Ministry of State security Personnel to
basically every investigative firm in
China and you know who are your foreign
clients what are they looking at you
know are any of them hedge funds are
they short sellers that basically
chilled that industry and they put a lot
of the government filings on lockdown as
well so it's today it's I mean almost
impossible to get these filings but
that's part of China's generally closing
itself off but everybody had forgotten
about this and didn't care in the U.S
until luck and coffee came along
now we didn't do the work on lucken uh
somebody else did we publicized it I
mean we went into their data room and
validated it um and I I know who did the
work so that also
um spoke to me a little bit more but um
yeah I mean the fraud there was just so
bad that the uh the auditor actually had
no choice but to find it when doing the
audit
um you know right after we had
publicized this third party's work
and so it's just funny talking to
reporters after lucking imploded when
you know they're saying wow this is
incredible like like bro this has been
the game forever and understand this and
I think this is the the big big point
that people really should take away from
the situation is if nobody gets punished
which again nobody except for one guy
who was Taiwanese has done prison time
in the U.S and I'm sure none of them
have done prison time in China for
defrauding U.S investors
it's heads I win Tails I don't lose if
this thing works out I make you know I
used to say tens of millions now it's
hundreds of millions maybe even north of
a billion if it doesn't work out
whatever what have I what have I lost
from doing this so
that's that's the thing and it you know
so people then after lock-in what
happened then was the SEC really started
looking at it again but they hated the
SEC hated and hates China cases because
just the amount of time it takes to get
stuff from China then you have to get it
translated incredibly resource intensive
and even once it's translated you don't
understand the legal context you know if
you're an SEC enforcement attorney you
have to bring in people who are experts
to explain it it's super resource
intensive and you almost never get
anything out of it because they're able
to sit in China and give the finger to
the U.S regulators and then China
codified that into law in 2021 where any
company must you know with with people
or assets in China must get Express
approval from the China Securities
Regulatory Commission before cooperating
with an overseas regulator so China puts
that in law that basically you can even
respond to the SEC even if you're listed
there so
you know there's there's no way of
protecting U.S investors and um
you know I'm I'm glad to see that the
cynicism toward China has returned but I
mean it was that was only after
countless hard lessons have been learned
by investors and you know what the
moment China's GDP really you know the
not the LIE the GDP number they
give you but like in reality the moment
China does start turning things around
economically everybody's going to want
to forget these lessons and rush in with
a bunch of cash and claim to have Edge
and oh I know you know I have a guanxi
over there and you know the cycle will
repeat because in the US we just can't
help ourselves
we're capitalists at the end of the day
another area where a ton of capital
continues to flow is artificial
intelligence uh it seems like in the
private Market specifically that is
basically holding or propping up the
Venture Capital kind of funding
environment is just put a uh on the name
uh on the end of a name and money will
show up at your door
um we're on the public markets are you
guys seeing the same type of thing where
there's tons of money pouring into
legitimate businesses or the
illegitimate what are you seeing in AI
well you're definitely seeing like a lot
of companies do the global find and
replace you know taking out servers and
putting AI or software AI so yeah
everybody's suddenly an AI play
um I mean maybe one of the just most
laughable ones and you know we're we're
short this name we haven't published on
it but it's a company called uh applied
digital
um those guys seem like a bunch of
jokers and some very questionable
dealings with um the Investment Bank B
Riley
um but yeah I think we're we haven't
seen a bunch of companies going public
yet that are you know AI plays that are
total scams I mean I'm that's coming
right but we're we've got kind of a you
know we've got a bit of a weak Market
that's you know I think been holding up
the IPOs but uh you know I mean if if
this were a few years ago before the SEC
really um put a chill on the SPAC Market
I mean you know the SPAC AI specs would
just be like the Golden Age age of being
an activist short seller all over again
you know or that plus the China reverse
mergers but yeah it's coming
guys like us will be all over it and you
know at the end of the day though you we
do need more of these companies out
there because
you know what what happens when there's
there's so much money flooding into a
space if there are really only a few
places for it to go like Nvidia you know
good luck like I'm not that Nvidia is a
scam but I mean even if it were like
good luck trying to break that because
it's the focal point in a relatively few
focal points for the money flooding into
AI but once you start increasing the
denominator here the money gets
sprinkled around then it's a lot easier
you know it's a lot easier to come out
and break the stock price when you can
present in compelling information about
why the you know investors have been
misled
how do you think about uh short sellers
making money one of the things
um and not your firm but there's an
article about Hindenburg right now
obviously they've been writing a bunch
of short reports and stuff
um but somebody broke down the math of
what they possibly could have made in
some of these shorts and what was
fascinating to me about it was less
about uh you know how much money they
are making or not making because it
wasn't you know fully confirmed it was
all kind of uh loose uh guesstimates if
you will but it was more of we're now
having a conversation about it where
people are realizing this could be a
viable investment strategy it could
actually make money uh people have been
talking about Longs like that forever
right and kind of the ability to go long
and make money and we can see you bought
the stock at X price and you got it at y
price whatever
I was actually pretty surprised to see
folks trying to back into the math of
like hey how much are the people
actually making on the short side
without sharing specific numbers or kind
of whatever you're comfortable with like
has the opportunity widened in terms of
you know the economic uh kind of capital
you can gain here or has it actually
shrunk as there's less short sellers or
less public companies like what are some
of the Dynamics that maybe feed into the
ability for short sellers to make money
doing this
well okay so it's for for one thing
there are a lot of activist short
sellers out there you just haven't heard
of most of them I mean so on Seeking
Alpha in any given day they're a bunch
of guys screaming at the top of their
lungs you know this is the worst thing
ever you know like writing about some 90
million market cap piece of and
you know like the world doesn't notice
them in the U.S we're we're used to this
sort of public criticism so guys like
that don't move the needle and in a lot
of them will try this for a little while
and then just you know flame out because
it's they're not getting traction and
what a lot of people forget about
Hindenburg
um is that you know that's I mean
Hindenburg and principal Nate Anderson
when he was grinding it out for years as
an act of a short seller didn't really
have much of a brand on you know this
was reported I think in the New York
Times but you know he was a one point
worried about getting evicted because he
you know he's having problems making his
rent payments and then they broke
through on Nikola and just you know
I mean blew up overnight right
um you know the Hindenburg brand and
they do great work and now they're
noticed but that's the thing like you
it's a very tough space at least with us
companies to break into it's a lot
easier in Europe because they're you
know Europe is much more a culture of
you know not criticizing people in
companies publicly and PS you don't have
the speech protections outside of the US
that you do in the U.S
um so that's that's another Dynamic now
even when you look at
guys like you know like me like Nate
um whatever you know make we make good
money I mean by most people's standards
in the world like we make pretty nice
money but
in finance if you think about it in in
finance industry terms first of all you
know the the amount of brain damage per
dollar that we earn is way off the scale
way off the charts relative to you know
just being like to close your eyes and
buy kind of you know business model
um because of all the litigation you
know like I mean I've now been through
you know three investigations
France Germany even the US which the US
wasn't supposed to happen and millions
and millions of dollars of legal fees
and just time sucks Etc
um you know on top of the companies that
Sue us and like that
um you know the death threats Etc so
you know even if you're you know even if
you're like oh that's good money I I
think I can make what Carson block makes
a lot of people when they start doing it
they're just like there are easier
ways you know if you're bright and
talented there are easier ways in this
industry of making that kind of money
absolutely why do I do it
I mean it's what I want to do like so
that's the thing and it's cliche but
it's cliche for a reason it comes back
to this you know you really have to
enjoy what you do you have to find
meaning and purpose in it because if
you're like yeah I'm gonna do this for
the money you're going to be gone in you
know within months probably because
you're just gonna find out it's such
there's so much here and it's
so hard
um so yeah I mean there there are a lot
of guys who like I said you know a new
one is probably born every day to go on
Seeking Alpha and scream about something
but the people who are relevant who have
staying power
um there aren't that many of us and you
know like and there's some some of whom
I have very high opinions of others of
whom I think suck and they cut corners
and they're doing they shouldn't be
doing so it's like every other industry
you know you've got people who operate
at a high level and do the right things
and then you've got people not so much
yeah it's interesting you describe it
this way in terms of
um uh like the brain damage per dollar
uh one of the things I've been
fascinated with and I've talked with a
number of investors who you know people
most people would know their names and
are highly respected as to why has there
not been a new young long activist
investor right if you go back to the
days of the Carl icons you know all
these people who like now are kind of
seen as Legends of Wall Street or people
who have been doing this a long time and
uh really kind of took the activist
approach and went in and fixed these
businesses and suggested things made a
lot of money doing it it doesn't seem
like there's really been anyone who's
kind of said hey I'm going to go do that
and one of one of the thought processes
has been it's a hard life right like
yeah yes there's social media there's
all these things you get but just
because you're long the stock same as
being short the stock like you're still
telling someone they're doing a bad job
right and and so it I wonder how much of
that plays into you know people just not
wanting to be as public maybe as maybe
they were back in the day before social
media before there was so much interest
on this activist you know type of
investing in either direction the
biggest fortunes aren't made on Wall
Street they used to be made there but
now they're being made in private
markets consider Mike Walsh he put five
thousand dollars into Uber he's just a
regular dude turned into over 24 million
dollars such opportunities were once
held behind closed doors reserved for
those who had connections or vast
fortunes but not anymore start engine is
now going to tear down that glass
ceiling and make startup Investments
possible for you and me the company is
led by Howard marks the co-founder of
gaming giant Activision and they got 1.7
million users that have put in over 1.2
billion dollars of transactions on the
platform but the best part is the
platform's not even backed by
traditional Venture capitalists it's
backed basically by the community
they've raised over 75 million dollars
in crowdsource funding to date go check
them out at startengine.com you can open
up a start engine account today and you
can explore live investing opportunities
with starting investing amounts as
little as a hundred dollars
startengine.com go check them out today
well I'm I'm speaking a little bit out
of school now because it's not what I do
but I mean we we have looked at
alongside activism as a business model
um in the past and so here are here are
my Impressions similar to short activism
it's very hard to break through I think
there are a lot of a lot of managers out
there trying to do alongside activism
but
um you know number one
eat it unless until you rate for most of
them unless and until you raise a
meaningful amount of AUM and can really
accumulate uh significant shares of the
voting stock
you know you're you're irrelevant so how
do you raise a bunch of AUM well you do
it with the track record of activism
okay but you know so you have this
chicken or egg problem number one number
two
um you know with all those years of free
money
um a lot of the low-hanging fruit was
plucked long ago in terms of you know
easy strategic fixes governance fixes
um you know what you know business fixes
and so what you ended up getting into
was
um I think a lot of alongside activism
did become this form of you know like
extractive capitalism basically where
it's like you don't have enough debt on
the balance sheet you know well you know
I want to run the business
conservatively for rainy day now shut up
you know if you oppose this idea of
Levering up your balance sheet you know
selling your real estate and leasing it
back
Etc then you know we're going to we'll
go to a proxy contest so what a lot of
it ended up becoming in the US was
Financial engineering which you know I'm
no fan of that I mean a lot of what we
look for are companies that are overly
financially engineered you know the
accounting is legal but it's very
misleading and it's covering up a lot of
rot within the business but it's this
type of extreme highly aggressive
Financial engineering by alongside
activists that can create the conditions
for Muddy Waters to later come in so um
but yeah I mean why you know why why
should I as an allocator give dollar to
this guy who's trying to break through
and you know be a financial engineer
when you know there are these other
better established players over there
but the final thing is and this is
you know and I and this is I think maybe
you know if you talk to the established
players this is probably the answer they
would give you is that look we were very
effective but we don't have to go public
to do it we don't want the goal is not
to go public and have a war the goal is
to be constructive behind the scenes
work with the board work with management
and you know and and basically generate
you know create value that way so
um see I think a lot of the most
successful activists I think they Define
themselves maybe that's a little bit too
strong a statement but I think a lot of
the most successful activists are
actually looking for you know
non-campaign campaigns just quiet behind
the scenes
um you know situations so yes it just it
doesn't generate the headlines but
that's where a lot of the action is yeah
that makes sense
um one of the last questions I have for
you is you all manage a fund so it's not
only just your Capital it's also outside
Capital you've had this impressive track
record I've seen in filings where you
guys have talked about you know I don't
know if it's eight nine ten different D
listings after you guys have kind of
published on companies and so
what is like the lp or the institutional
kind of appetite for this type of stuff
right and what I mean by that is I think
it's twofold it's like one there's an
investment strategy right of kind of
activist Short Selling but then there's
also this idea of like if I allocate to
Muddy Waters uh I also am then dealing
with like is Carson going to get a death
threat today right is like you know is
there going to be a lawsuit like there's
all these other components to it and so
like how have you seen maybe that change
over time as well especially when you
know you first started out you were
based in China you were going after
Chinese companies it was kind of like
you you were really doing research and
stuff like that to like now you're a
full-blown asset manager who's got a
track record and you know I think most
people would agree or one of if not the
best short sellers over the last you
know 15 20 years
how does the institutional World kind of
respond to this or what does that
environment look like today
that's uh so yeah um
I mean look our our LP base is you know
it it's generally speaking smaller
institutions and ultra high net worth um
individuals and the the reality is with
activist Short Selling you know people
might look at the numbers and say whoa
you know great numbers or whatever but
it's not scalable really there's you
know it's not you cannot manage a
billion dollars in AUM in an activist
Short Selling strategy like it just no
why not no I I mean
because you just so you're only be most
of us I mean us anyway we're generally
gonna be out there five or maybe six
times a year on a company and the trade
capacities if the companies that are
that are generally better situated
um for activist Short Selling are the
ones that don't have as much sell side
coverage so they're they're mid caps and
actually very few short activists can
swing a bat in the mid cap space most
are in the micro cap in small cap space
because that's where you get the most
egregious behaviors so we have the
resources to really deconstruct complex
mid-cap type situations but you know at
the end of the day these are not large
caps so we can only have so much money
in the trade like the trades only have
so much capacity and if we're doing this
only five or six times a year I mean
call it even four to six
um there's just not that that much money
that we can actually put to work
productively so that's the you know the
the issue with short activism people
could look at the numbers and be like
wow great numbers but yeah you can't
scale it to be that big and you know and
if you do then the tail starts wagging
the dog you're looking for like large
liquid companies as opposed to
problematic companies you know let's
look at this large liquid company and
see if we can find some problems so I
think that
you know I I think really trying to
scale you know much bigger than we are I
mean we we returned Capital at one point
um you know because we're just like look
this is too much you know we we can't
put this much to work so that's the
issue there now I mean in terms of LP
base
um yeah so smaller institutions I mean
we'll we'll never be pretty enough in
this space for Sovereign wealth fund I
mean our our investors generally are
like look we we we're not worried about
headline risk we don't have that big a
name so like nobody's gonna give a
that you know like blah blah blah backs
Muddy Waters now we do have a few
investors who do have some name brands
based on the type of institution they
are but you know they I mean look they
they they believe in what we do they
understand that we're keeping markets
honest
um and they have to get comfortable with
the idea that you know at the end of the
day if it came out that you were
invested with us like it's not it's not
going to be the end of the world right
like people would forget it pretty
quickly and it's not even a story to
begin with so um so there's that but
yeah we uh you know
um there's a lot of you know I I got to
tell you you know they're you know we we
spend a lot of time or I've spent a lot
of time uh insulting certain Sovereign
wealth funds and their governments so
like the Saudis
um so I don't think we're ever going to
get like uh pif money uh you know like
some of the other you know and we've
we've made we've made comments about
norge's Bank as well about how I mean
you know they're they're great like SEC
lenders you know if you see norges in
something I mean they own all this dog
around the world but um anyway so
yeah that's uh
it's a very Niche type of LP who's who's
interested in investing with us and I
guess the final thing is to that like
you know for me
um
I'm not gonna be what a lot of
institutional investors would want me to
be right you're not going to come into
the office meet with me I'm not going to
wear a suit
um I'm not going to have that
institutional looking office I'm not
gonna refrain from you know saying
this that
um
and like that's that's those are the
behaviors that you undertake if you
really care about raising money but you
know my attitude is like look I want you
to understand what we're all about
because you know if you you know if you
have a problem you know with this then
like we're not we're not a good match
let's save each other time and you know
and you're not gonna you know worry like
ah does he smoke weed because the answer
is yes not before meetings and stuff but
you know like I just you got to be
comfortable with us personally and
professionally
um you know to is is my view and so yeah
I we're not going to pretend to be
you know more polished than we are yeah
that makes sense to me my last question
for you is there's a bunch of companies
that were really really hot private
companies they went public Mass
evaluations I'm thinking we work I'm
thinking BuzzFeed you know all these
different businesses they now have drawn
down significantly someone even argue
maybe they are mid caps at this point
right and kind of like in I'm not saying
that they're doing anything wrong I
don't even know if anyone has come out
and publicly said that they've you know
done fraud or anything like that but
just like now the size is significantly
lower than they were what do you think
happens to those types of companies like
are that is that like a things in motion
stay in motion and they're likely to
just keep going down over time and
eventually get delisted do you think
that there's like a theme in some of
these really hot private companies from
years ago hey the Market's just down and
like it'll come back and those companies
will benefit how do you kind of think of
maybe like this cohort of I'll call it
like Tech and Tech enabled businesses
that got tons of private funding went
public and the public markets
essentially have rejected those
valuations and reset them at something
much lower
it's an interesting question
um because the short answer is I I don't
know but it's interesting because
um you know I used to joke some years
ago that uh 700 million is the new zero
right like nothing ever went to went to
zero and now I think you could even say
like the new zero is like north of a
billion um you know I think there's a
lot psychologically that happens here
where investors will look just
reflexively look like well Peak market
cap was like you know 22 billion so at
like 1.3 you know there's got to be some
value there which is a totally
non-scientific ass backward way of
valuing a company but I think that
that's effectively what goes on so you
know what ends that
um so I I don't know I mean you look at
wework it's it's funny because I mean
that business model has always been a
bad business model it's just a rent
Arbitrage and like yeah it was cool you
know cool offices right you spent a lot
more on your you know on your cap acts
you know on your FF and O then like
Regis did but Regis has been bankrupt at
least once I think maybe twice
um it's always been a business
model so but do people will it always
hold some Allure for a long time hold
some Allure because it used to be like
SoftBank valued it at like what almost
50 billion
um I mean people still think SoftBank is
smart money like people still care what
Masa thinks I mean it's you know it's
the biggest joke on the planet so um
okay maybe not the biggest but in Masa
in SoftBank have certainly been you know
the butt of many jokes internally even
before you know like all this this stuff
hit the skids
um where we are but uh but yeah I so I
don't I don't know
um but I I think that inherently that we
work business model
um a rent ARB is just such a difficult
business model maybe you could run it
profitably at a relatively small scale
but you know that's probably A Better
Private Business than a public business
yeah that makes sense and it um I think
just speaks to kind of like the way you
think about the business right it's like
at the end of the day you can put all
the bells and whistles on it it's a rent
Arbitrage business and is that a good
business or not and
um one of the aspects uh that I think
I've really paid attention to is the
public narratives on Plenty of business
well public and private uh
it isn't the same as maybe you know kind
of a direct just boil it down to what is
it and I do wonder how much of that is
uh in the mainstream media uh certain
journalists they just don't they're
they're ill prepared to combat the
professional Communications teams like I
think a lot about you know like if you
are um a journalist at one of these
mainstream outlets and I have plenty of
friends that are there that are amazing
and I have plenty of friends there that
I'm like hey you probably should go find
a different you know role right and and
they probably know that but the ones who
are not skilled who are not trained to
have not been doing it for a long time
they get run over by the communications
teams right and then Vice verses the
ones are really good they're calling
left and right it's like you
know like the referee who just throws
the yellow flag every single play on the
football field right they're like that's
not true that's not true whatever and so
um you know you described earlier short
sellers like there's really good ones
and there's ones who aren't so great I
think you see that uh in companies you
see that in the journalism side and so
really it's when you're reading this
stuff trying to figure out who are the
really high quality journalists that
when you read it you know that they're
just not rewriting the press release
they actually have done work and and you
know you can kind of put more I think
weight on it and so you know how many
articles got written about wework as a
rent Arbitrage business not that many
right I mean there's a movie they don't
really talk about that that much
yeah well it's it's funny I I know one
of um The Venture I know principal at
one of the wework Spencer backers and
um and this is before it this is you
know maybe a couple years ago
um I sat down with him and um
it's just funny we had these really
different takes on Adam Newman and I I
was I I got into it first I was like you
know as soon as I read this article in
the Ft about how he was having these
Retreats and you know and he's and he's
preaching veganism and you know but he
actually apparently really eats meat
like I knew this guy's a like a
total scammer like that's that's a
that's a glimpse of how he really thinks
about the world I you know I assume you
know you really are you know would never
you know put money with a guy like that
again he's like no you're wrong like he
was probably the best salesman I'd ever
met
and you know I'm like but yeah that's a
problem right like that's a guy I want
to short a good salesman he's like no
that's a guy I want to go long and
Venture because you know he's going to
be able to you know convince more people
to put in more money at higher
valuations and eventually convince
Somebody To You Know bring up like you
know bring them public And subscribe to
the IPO and you know so in the Venture
World they want the salesman the short
sellers we want the salesmen you know
we're just different parts of the life
cycle I guess you know is is the is is
the irony you should go look at that
Venture uh capitalist portfolio maybe
there's a good short ideas in there for
uh when they're public well he's
actually one of the guys who's like more
of a like purist and Zealot and like you
know I it's you know it's something I um
it's something I puzzle over with uh you
know I so several a couple of years ago
um we had some interns and I brought
them to New York and I sat down with a
guy who's CEO of yeah reasonable size
Investment Bank and um he you know he
finished making he made a point or he
told the story and then he said to the
interns I said you know reputation is
everything and you know you can't
sacrifice your reputation you've got to
be honest and above board and this and
that and you know I'm like nodding and
like yes that's exactly correct but then
he told the story which is a great story
and I'll try to Nutshell it but he got
into he got into the business in
Investment Banking in the 80s
um he went to a school that Banks didn't
recruit from so he sent in applications
he was getting rejected everywhere so he
took his first Boston rejection letter
and was signed by somebody in HR so he
called up the first Boston switchboard
in New York and he said yeah give me uh
you know I want to talk to a vice
president you know not understanding
that like everybody at a bank is a VP
and you know the switchboard operator
said which one and he's like well just
start reading from the directory
alphabetically so you know Jim Adams
yeah I'll talk to Jim Adams Jim Adams
picks up the phone he says hi my name's
so-and-so and he looks at that letter
the woman who signed it the HR uh uh you
know person who signed it and says yeah
uh Sharon Michaels uh told me I should
call you to set up an interview oh oh
okay yeah so he totally like finagles
this interview goes in the guy's like
man you're great let me introduce you to
uh you know my director and the director
is like bam you know great interview you
know let me introduce you to an MD and
so by the end of the day an MD calls
that calls down to the person in HR and
it's like yeah you know we're giving
this guy an offer she's like well we we
can we rejected him you know like no
you're hiring him so he got hired like
what a great story like the you know the
the hood spot like it's awesome
but we just finished saying don't
people you know be honest your
reputation is everything and so the
lesson here is that there's an
acceptable if not optimal level of
in this world and that the
world especially in finance runs on some
level of and so it's an
interesting philosophical question to
ponder you know when have you crossed
the line like when when is your level of
too much and I think if we look
at Elon Musk it's
you know it's like a great case study I
mean this guy lies a lot but he also
delivers on stuff too like he built the
car the rocket flies Etc so
you know like net net where you know and
on the short side I will admit a lot of
people have Elon Musk derangement
syndrome
um but
you know but he does lie a lot so it's
uh it's it's an interesting it's an
interesting yeah this has fascinating to
me because
how do you get at um
if you were talking to the founder right
let's say you're talking to Elon and you
said to Elon hey why did you say x and I
don't know let's say it was uh
delivering the vehicle on a certain
timeline it's like one of the the
critiques right it's he'll say a
timeline and then the car's not
delivered and he would say uh at the
moment when he says it he's like because
we're gonna do it but he full-on
believes that he's not you know
bullshitting and trying to lie or
manipulate the stock price or whatever
so let's just hold constant for a second
the the assumption that like he fully
believes that is the timeline and
because he chooses the timeline that is
ridiculously short and aggressive he
doesn't hit it
what I've always wondered is like
in on one regard like we need a guy like
that to be able to make the car and fly
the rocket and like do all that kind of
stuff on the same side right like when
you evaluate what he's saying you're
like this is there's no way
he's going to deliver a brand new car in
two months right and like even the
engineers probably working on her like
dude two months like if I sleep at the
factory maybe three right but like two
months is like impossible
I I guess it like kind of gets into this
weird world of like if he believes it
and he's just being overly optimistic
and he eventually does deliver the car
but it's like a timeline Thing versus
take like an Enron where it's like a
just an accounting fraud and it's just
like hey these people are lying right
how does the market view that because I
think elon's this fascinating example of
like there are people who literally will
yell and scream all day long about how
Elon is the greatest thing since Jesus
and then there's other people who are
like this guy lies all the time and is
full of and like by the way I'm
complaining on Twitter right right where
like he's it's like I don't know how do
you like balance it and maybe there
isn't a right answer but I think he is
maybe like the epitome of this you know
kind of conundrum if you will
yeah no I I mean he's definitely he
definitely is the epitome of the you
know of that that tension you know we
all believe in honesty but you know and
the reality is so I or I shouldn't say
the reality is my assumption is
I think he understands a lot of times
that he's lying and and it's not just
you know making pronouncements about the
future that are too optimistic but even
saying talking about things that are or
are not
um but I think he understands this but
you know the short case was always
predicated on hey you're going to get
crushed by the majors right you're not
you don't have a large enough sales base
you know so your unit costs are going to
be too high and everybody was looking at
the manufacturing base
but what Elon I think was focused on and
what only he understood and you know
like every day on the short side it just
took too long to under many I think do
not understand this is that What
mattered was the capital base so by Me
by getting Tesla's market value so high
right even if you know like the I mean
they're they're not going to run out of
cash because they can keep issuing stock
all the way I mean there's so much you
know I I mean I'm not sure where the cap
is right now but as of a couple of years
ago when I when I had this this thought
it was about double that of Toyota
Motors right so
I think he got that hey in order to
compete with these guys in order to have
staying power
I need to have massive market cap
and I think you said I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to have that massive
market cap so
you know maybe maybe it's a bit you know
of an armchair quarterback to say well
yeah but you really didn't have to be
that egregious in a number of these
pronouncements you know um
I mean maybe he didn't uh but you know
and do I think that he should still be
held accountable despite the fact that
and like people on the short side hate
when I say this but
he did move the needle he pushed the
world toward electrification of vehicles
much faster than it would have gone
without the majors now again I will you
know we can dive into this and explain
why well if you're filling up your car
with coal-fired power you're probably
better off with like you know six
cylinder internal combustion engine but
putting that to the side you know the
future of humanity at some point does
need to be based on electrification
which I would argue for nuclear you know
nuclear powered electrification but
um but yeah he's um you know but but I
think that I think that's what the game
was he just he knew he needed the market
cap because otherwise he couldn't he
couldn't do it
um but unfortunately I feel like he
can't turn off that you know it's he was
rewarded you know as he pushed the
needle I think he I think he's changed a
lot personality wise over the years I
mean I don't know him well like I met
him one time back in like 13 but
I feel like he's changed a lot
personality wise over the years because
if you're you know if you cross the line
and you get a positive reward it's very
pavlovian I think this process so
um I don't know that he's what I would
consider to be a good person anymore uh
good at heart but
look he's done some he's done some
things that need to be done and I guess
when where I'm where I most admire him
is actually in the space realm because
uh you know I I knew somebody who used
to be very senior at Nasa on the
technology side and I mean he told me
things like the average age of a NASA
engineer at that time was you know like
in the upper 50s and they still program
in like Fortran because these are
government jobs and it's clear like the
future of space for America is it has to
be private sector so and you know and
Boeing sucks you know overruns and you
know and elon's gotten it he's got it
done in that in that area so um you know
hat tip to him Carson that's a great
place for us to end where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find out more about Muddy Waters
uh well I mean I've got a I'm not that
active on Twitter or X which is
something Elon has up but uh
that's at Muddy Waters re and uh we
publish our research
um uh muddywatersresearch.com
um unfortunately we don't check the info
boxes often as we should but uh there's
also yeah so but anyway that's that's
the best way to do it awesome I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this we'll definitely do it again in the
future
all right thanks man enjoyed it